مشاهدينا الكرام ونحن على ابواب اليوم
الثاني عشر من هذه المعارك تبدو الخرطوم
العاصمه هي محور العمليات العسكريه خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه رغم ان التهدئه
لا تزال تسري وان ببعض الخروقات التي
يتبادل الاتهامات فيها الطرفان الدعم
السريع والجيش اذا ما انتقلنا مباشره الى
العاصمه الخرطوم المعلوم بطبيعه الحال بان
العاصمه الخرطوم تنقسم الى ثلاثه اقسام
القسم الشرقي خرطوم بحري والقسم الغربي هو
ام درمان والقسم الجنوبي هي مدينه الخرطوم
ثلاث مدن التي تشكل العاصمه الخرطوم او ما
يعرف بالخرطوم الكبرى الدعم السريع يقول
اليوم بان القوات الجيش السوداني
الطائراتها حلقت بكثافه في منطقتي خرطوم
بحري وام درمان مع بعض العمليات العسكريه
في وسط خرطوم بحري بجوار نهر النيل وايضا
في اندرمان ولكن لا يمكن القول كانت ضربات
عنيفه وواسعه النطاق في المنطقتين المنطقه
الاساسيه التي شهدت العمليات العسكريه هي
المنطقه الجنوبيه من مدينه الخرطوم الكبرى
او مدينه الخرطوم هذه محافظه الخرطوم
الكبرى وهذه مدينه الخرطوم مدينه الخرطوم
عند ملتقى النيلين الازرق والابيض كانت
مسرح العمليات وهي حقيقه هي مسرح العمليات
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه لانه اداء
السيطره او الدعم او التعزيزات تتركز في
هذه النقطه لماذا تتركز بهذه النقطه لاننا
نتحدث عن هذا المربع بالغ الاهميه والذي
لا يتجاوز حتى هذه اللحظه عدد بسيط من
الكيلومترات يعني المسافه بين النيل
الازرق من هنا الى هذه الى هذه النقطه
مطار الخرطوم حوالي اثنين كيلو متر فقط
والمسافه من هذه النقطه من عند المطار حتى
المنطقه الشرقيه نتحدث عن اربعه كيلو
مترات فقط او اقل من ذلك لماذا هذه
المنطقه هي مسرح العمليات لانه انا بتحدث
عن مقر القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
والقصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم الدولي
قوات الدعم السريع تتخذ من هذه المواقع
نقاط ارتكاز لها في مقر القياده العامه
وفي محيط المقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه وهو ما يعرف بحي المطار والمنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه من مطار الخرطوم الدولي
وايضا في محيط القصر الجمهوري قوات الدعم
السريع اليوم تقول بان القوات الجيش
اخترقت الهدنه
بمهاجمه قوات الدعم السريع الموجوده في
محيط القصر الجمهوري بينما يقول الجيش ان
قوات الدعم السريع اخترق اخترق الهدنه
اليوم باستهداف قوات الجيش المنتشره في
هذه المناطق الجيش يقول بانه ينفذ عمليات
تمشيط خلال الايام القليله الماضيه في هذه
المنطقه الصغيره هذا المربع الامن الصغير
بحثا عن مقاتلي الدعم السريع ولكن الصوره
لم تتوقف على الخرطوم العاصمه او حتى
مدينه الخرطوم وحسب الجيش السوداني يقول
وهذه خريطه اوسع للسودان الجيش السوداني
يقول بان قوات الدعم السريع تتقدم من
المناطق الغربيه باتجاه الخرطوم العاصمه
والمناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه لان هذه
المناطق هي مناطق تمركز
لقوات الدعم السريع خلال السنوات الماضيه
وبالتالي كانت المناطق الغربيه والجنوبيه
الغربيه هي الداعم الاساسي لقوات الدعم
السريع في الضغط على الخرطومه العاصمه
طبعا نحن نتحدث عن مساحات واسعه من وسط
الخرطوم حتى هذه المنطقه حوالي 1200 كيلو
متر وبالتالي العمليات العسكريه تتركز في
هذه المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه والغربيه
هذه العمليات العسكريه ادت الى نزوح
الالاف حتى هذه اللحظه الحديث عن عشره
الاف نازح خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
ولكن السودان فيه اكثر من ثلاثه فاصله
سبعه مليون نازح بسبب اضطرابات القبليه
والعنف الدائر في البلاد منذ اكثر من سنه
تكون هذه الاحداث الاخيره تزيد من كاهل
العمليه الانسانيه والاوضاع الانسانيه
بشكل عام في السودان هذه المعلومات بطبيعه
الحال بحاجه الى مزيد من التحليل والتفصيل
وستكون مع ال سي شكرا لك صهيب